A agents for software engineering have
been exploding in popularity over the
last year and we wanted to find out just
how good are they at finding and fixing
bugs. Can you even rely on them for
maintenance? Well, that's what we're
going to tell you here today at a
engineers world fair. Uh, hey guys,
we're Bismouth and we've been working on
software agents for the last year in
some change. My name is Ian and I'm the
CEO of Bismouth. So, my background was
in data engineering, machine learning,
and search. Previously, I was at Zillow
as a senior edge on the AB testing
platform. Uh, and this is my second time
working deeply on dev tooling at a
startup. Um, I started with technical
documentation search in 2019 along with
Nick here building an index of hundreds
of millions of technical documents for
inline IDE use along with AI
summarization for internal knowledge
bases. Hey, so I'm Nick, CTO of
Bismouth. Um, I was primarily in the
software security space before starting
Bismouth with Ian. Um, I was at Google
just prior on an internal tools team
building endpoint security software and
before that I was a research scientist
focused on detecting software
exploitation. Um there's a lot of tools
and techniques from that space that
transfer to building intelligent agentic
code tools. It turns out before we get
started just want to shout out base 10
for helping provide credits and compute
for running our benchmark across both
DeepSec R1 and Llama for Maverick.
Thanks guys. We really appreciate it.
Thank
you. So to dive right in, we wanted to
share with you all the benchmark we've
been building for a few months now to
explore just how good software agents
are at coding tasks outside of the
normal feature development. There's a
handful of benchmarks already to measure
how effective LLMs are for writing code.
Human
evaluator's polyglot benchmark uh and
live codebench just to name a few. But
of course that's only one part of the
software development life cycle and what
developers do. So what about the rest of
the SDLC? Well, uh initial scoping and
planning is kind of an entirely
different task, right? It requires
broader business context, knowledge of
existing systems and designs, exploring
potential existing solutions and so on.
Um, it's basically a completely
different task from development. Um,
next we have the feature dev and testing
which are already pretty well covered by
the existing benchmarks. Um, and then
there's the code review process which is
pretty much unbenchmarked by existing
work even though we're seeing more and
more LLM based tools in the space. Uh
and this is actually the first part of
our
benchmark. Deployment is a pretty
separate task requiring not just writing
configuration but also setting up
monitoring, integrating with other
existing systems, etc. It's also pretty
distinct. Um last and le last and not
least though we have software
maintenance tasks. So think things like
bug fixes, dependency upgrades,
migrations, etc. Um, this is another
part of the SLC that at its core is
still generally writing code but is in a
distinctly different way than feature
development. So the ability to reason
through a codebase deeply defined bugs
is directly transferable to being able
to produce features. You can think about
how like when you're dividing a feature,
you're going to learn the architecture
of the codebase. You're going to learn,
you know, how everything connects, the
data flow and stuff like that. So that's
the same for finding bugs. In both
cases, you need an understanding of the
system architecture and its
connectedness. Um, in the case of
finding bugs, you even often need to
understand the system more deeply than
when you originally wrote the feature in
the first place. Um, to that end,
maintenance requires the ability to
first deeply reason through a system and
identify if bugs are potentially
present. We found agents struggle with
holistic evaluation of files and
systems, only finding subsets of bugs
per run. Thinking models alleviate this
somewhat, but reasoning appears to be
somewhat narrow, only exploring a
limited number of potential avenues at a
single time. This is translated directly
to LLM's missing bugs that human
developers would pick up almost
immediately and confirming bugs that
human developers would discard almost
immediately. While there is value here,
the ability is clearly still in its
infancy. When it comes to patching of
these bugs, because of the relative
simplicity that we have seen from them,
they usually get it uh without much of
an effort. But again, because the bugs
themselves are not particularly complex,
this isn't really saying much.
Yeah. So there are some existing bug
detection benchmarks from the software
security space, but there's some big
limitations that don't really make them
suitable for evaluating these new
agentic AI systems since they were built
to benchmark kind of classic static
analysis or program repair tools. Uh
they focus on relatively simplistic bugs
in common patterns, things like null
pointer dreerences, buffer overflows,
maybe SQL injection in a web app, which
could all be found statically. Um, a lot
of the benchmarks are also really
limited in the languages that they pull
from. So many of them are only Java for
instance because that's where the vast
majority of enterprise complicated
software was and honestly still is
written. Um, there's also a bias towards
security issues in the existing
benchmarks partly as a result of that
being where the classic static analysis
tools are focused. Um, but bugs appear
in many more ways than just security
defects, right? Copy paste bugs are a
really simple example where they don't
often result in an off bypass, for
example, but it breaks the software to
end users all the same, right? So, how
does our benchmark SM
compare? So, we painstakingly gathered
100 bugs that we triaged, validated, and
classified in over 84 public
repositories. These are bugs that have
all been remediated already but are
represented in the wild and work in open
source by various developers across all
levels. Our goal when assembling these
bugs was to provide a range of issue
types from obvious low specific domain
knowledge all the way to senior staff
level engineering knowledge with
significant depth of understanding for a
given project. We also wanted to make
sure we provide a multi- language
benchmark as LMS have notably different
performance across them. Here we focused
on Python, TypeScript, JavaScript, and
Go first because Python and Typescript
JavaScript are languages that are the
most popular and LMS are supposedly
better at performing on them. Then we
chose Go as kind of a control to balance
performance on a low-level systems
engineering
language. So looking ahead, here's an
example of what we mean by an objective
bug. Um, this is anything an explicit
security issue or logical issue that
could cause data loss or system crashes.
The reason we went for these types of
bugs is it removes anything uh that is
ambiguous um or harmless in the context
of the system uh or performs correctly
if you look one level up and the thing
that calls it kind of bounds the problem
anyway. Um an example of this uh is a
function that doesn't check bounds uh
but the code is called uh but the code
that it's called from ensures the input
never goes over those bounds anyway. So
in isolation that's a bug but in the
context of the system there's there's no
failure point. Um, we explicitly did not
include feature requests, optimization,
style formatting or design decisions.
Uh, this is also to reduce ambiguity.
Uh, frankly, humans still debate these
to today. There's no actual objective
kind of discourse around them. It's
whatever your like uh codra decides they
want to use. It also helps make it
reproducible across evaluations. And as
alluded to earlier, uh we annotated each
bug with metadata such as the severity
and context where it was defined and
called. Uh how much system specific
domain knowledge a human would require
to find the bug. How difficult even with
said knowledge it would be to find it.
So even if you're an expert in the
system, how long it would take you to
navigate and get that bug and finally
the implication of the bug itself. Was
it a data loss? Was it a crash? Is it a
security exploit? Etc.
These classifications allow us to
understand what level of bugs these AI
agents are capable of finding regularly.
We note that every once in a while they
surprise us such in that recent blog
post where 03 was able to find um a zero
day exploit. Uh but notably there it
took about a 100 runs to actually get it
over the same context each time. Um so
while that's still useful to know
they're possible, it's more useful to
know in everyday usage how are they
capable um on just everyday tasks.
So for each system that we benchmarked,
there's four numbers to get out of the
benchmark. The first is just can the
system discover the bugs without any
prior knowledge. Uh we call this the
needle in the haystack result. And we'll
talk a bit more about the specifics of
our methodology for this in just a
second. Um of course though, when the
agents produce a list of bugs, there's a
lot more than just the one that we're
looking for. So we also manually measure
the false positive rate of the bugs that
come out to get an overall sense of how
effective it is broadly. Um we also look
at whether the system can find the bug
at the time of introduction. So given
the pull request or commit that
introduces the bug, can the agent point
it out at that point? Um, of course here
the agent doesn't have to go searching
to find issues and has a lot more kind
of immediate context around it. So with
a bit more of an optimistic starting
point, how good can they be? Um, and
finally, we still do want to see how the
agents uh do with suggesting
remediations for the things that it
identifies. Uh and so for each bug that
it discovers, we ask it to fix the bug
uh and see if the result does indeed fix
the bug without breaking the rest of the
codebase. Oh yeah, by far. So jumping
back uh to needle in the haststack now
we don't want to just tell agents you
know go find bugs somewhere in the
repository because frankly most of the
things that we're measuring are big
enough we're exploring all of the code
to find the single bug that we're
interested in would take way too long.
Uh and we also don't though want to hint
at what the actual bug is in the
evaluation. We don't want to bias them
in any way. So how do we solve this? uh
well we've broken up the repositories
into subsystems containing files that
are likely all interrelated. So think
you know maybe part of a front end or
some specific uh API uh point. We then
feed the list of files in that subsystem
uh or sorry we then filter the
subsystems that were that contain the
files that were modified kind of in the
golden PR commit and just feed the files
in those subsystems to the LLM. So it's
getting a reduced list of files in the
entire
repository. This way we're not biasing
it in any way, but we're still scoping
it down so it doesn't have to look
through everything. Uh, and we can still
get an idea of what this works or how
well this works in like a nonbenchmark
capacity. It's just looking at one part
of the code, but that in its entirety.
Okay. So, what does it take to actually
get a system up to a level of beating
some of the biggest companies and labs
in the world? So, basic implementations
are trivial. Give it a shell tool, sir,
replace, think, report bug, you know, a
finish tool, put it in a loop, and press
play. So, you do have an agent here.
It's running. It's looking at code
files. Um, and you might even find some
bugs. We actually found five or six in
the basic loop here. Uh, but they also
had a 97% false positive rate. So,
almost every basic agent that just
equipped with these tools from like the
anthropic model card releases or open AI
methodology releases, um, are not up to
the task of really finding bugs and
triaging systems.
So, it's actually really hard to build a
good agent for identifying bugs and
working on code. It's a combination of
model, system, prompting, information,
the way you feed that information to a
model, and navigation
strategy. Um, if you look at our numbers
for performance comparisons, you can see
right off the bat that Bismouth leads
the pack for needle in a haststack. Um,
we found 10 of our needles. Uh, the next
leading solution finding seven. So we do
note off the bat there's a lot of room
to grow here but if anything we're
excited that we found an unsaturated
benchmark to work on uh as we build our
product and as other labs build theirs.
I will say we are starting to see some
exciting things on true positive rate
and detection though uh with claude code
starting out at 16% us at 25% in second
place and codeex at 45%. You'll also
note that for these three solutions I
just mentioned we find significantly
less like random nonsense compared to
the rest of the pack. like we just have
a tighter scoping. Uh Devon, cursor
agent uh and cosign all found between
900 and 1,200 items or 1300 items for
cursor uh with between a 3 and 10% true
positive rate. So there's a lot of um
headway for those agents to go on PR
review. Uh codeex was quite strong uh
with 20 uh 27% of the needle in
haststack found then devon at 21 and
then us at 17. So, one thing to note
there is that those do not include any
false positives that had been found uh
during those PR reviews. This is just
did it find the needle in the haystack.
And even there, you'll note that the
best model only got 27. So about a
third, uh there's a long way to go on
both PR review and bug detection.
I want to note that given the models
here uh bismouth itself is agnostic uh
but we typically run on top of anthro
anthropic models and they've been easier
to serve for our customers from vertex
uh in this instance our solution was
able to beat uh their own solution cloud
code in multiple categories uh while
improving on their base
model. So let's move on to looking at
what we call basic agents. Uh these are
agents that are the simple loop we
described earlier. And we were able to
actually look at a couple open source
models here as well. And we'll note just
off the bat um open source has a long
way to come in this space. Um R1 only
had a 1% true positive rate uh over what
like hundreds uh yeah yeah over hundreds
of bugs. Um same with Lava Maverick at a
2%. Um R1 did manage to find um a needle
in a hay stack. Um but both of these
were lapped by sonnet 4 and 03 in a loop
um where sonnet 4 found six uh and 03
found two with a 3% and 6% uh false uh
true positive rate respectively. The
hard truth here is that the highest
popular agent score outside of us who
are just launching now uh scored 7% on
SM 100. Um that means the most used
agents in the world are the worst at
finding and fixing complex bugs. Uh this
is a problem for the industry that we're
hoping to bring to light and we're
hoping to see that these teams will
begin to work on this to increase their
score in what represents the back 90% of
work for software
engineering. It's also important to note
that three out of six agents got 10% or
less true positives out of a massive
number of reports. Uh on one issue, an
agent gave us an astounding 70 reports
and nobody's going to actually sift
through that many, right? Like no
engineer is going to look through 70
bugs and be like, "Oh yeah, that one for
sure is the right one." So there's a
long way to go on tightening how much
information these agents are reporting
and the accuracy of that information
itself. I think that you know in
context that even some simple bugs are
missed. um only two agents bismouth and
codeex found this state issue and the
consequence of the state issue is pretty
simple right when you submit a form um
usually they clear in this particular
case uh is dirty was never set to false
uh so it would never clear the form and
it would say you still had things filled
out you know that's not the biggest bug
in the world but that has real
consequences for users and user
experience and that's the type of things
a human developer would immediately
catch so we think there is a large way
to go
So after examining uh all of the
performance across all these different
agents, there was a notable commonality
between them. These agents are very
narrow in their thinking. Even when
using thinking models, this is actually
a problem. It's more of a problem on
non-thinking models, but thinking models
themselves are very narrow in the types
of things they're evaluating. And we
find that even with that narrowness,
they don't go deep enough. So from our
perspective, broader thinking chains and
deeper thinking along selected chains is
going to be required to actually find
bugs in these files. It's also
interesting to note that on a perr run
basis, the total number of bugs remains
roughly consistent, but the bugs
themselves change. So that means from
any one particular run an LLM is not
looking holistically at a file and
inventorying everything that's
happening. Um we suspect there's
different biases occurring uh in that
and that the models themselves you know
through whatever context have been
provided are looking at a file one way
and not another way. Um there's
methodologies we thought of to solve
that but right now it seems like that is
a pervasive problem across every agent
in the industry and no one has quite
solved that. So there's a broader
problem here, right? Despite 60 to 70%
80% in some cases scores on Sweet
Edenge, agents still struggle with SM
100. What does that mean? Existing
agents are able to create software
upfront, but to manage and fix software
after it's been deployed will be a major
struggle as far as we see it. And this
is a hard problem that teams are working
on across the board, us included. But it
demands targeted search, better program
comprehension, crossfile reasoning, bug
pattern recognition that we just don't
see in deep capacity from many of these
solutions. Now, we're hopeful here
because codecs, for instance, and us are
starting to show tighter narrow tighter,
more narrow bands of the bugs that it's
solving. We do get some complex issues.
We are one of the two agents that found
that bug I mentioned earlier. So, as we
progress here, we hope the industry
evolves and focuses more on this
problem. So, to wrap things up, we know
that the most frequently used agents
today have a high risk of introducing
bugs. Though, as we just said, a few of
the newer agents as part of this new
generation, including us, are starting
to show an increased ability to reason
through code and more effectively use
their context to evaluate concerns.
Stability is nent, but so far what we've
seen has been encouraging. Uh and with
this benchmark, we can now clearly show
as things progress. Um with effort and
some different techniques, you can do
better and improvements here will have
benefits across the entire industry. We
have many things that we want to try and
I'm sure other labs do. Uh and we're
really excited to be on the forefront of
this new generation of
agents. So, thanks for watching. Uh you
can dive into numbers and get more
details on the benchmark uh at the
website. Uh, and be sure to check us out
at
bismouth.sh. Thank you. Thanks.